hey guys so a few of you asked me to
make a video on the best shampoo and
conditioner for men we all use shampoo a
few times every day right and
conditioner but we don't realize just
how important the right shampoo and a
right conditioner is for our hair type
most guys think that gray hair is all
about the right wax or pomade or
hairspray or style but great hair
actually starts in the shower using the
right shampoo and the right conditioner
to treat your hair so in this video
we're gonna look at the best shampoo and
conditioner for all hair types so let's
get right into the video guys if this is
the first time that you're here on my
channel welcome i'm daniel consider
subscribing and also clicking the
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next videos now let's start with
the best shampoo and conditioner for men
with thin hair
first up is brickel's daily
strengthening shampoo and also they
revitalizing conditioner these two are
great for men of any age it doesn't
matter how old you are because it works
great in really strengthening and making
your hair look fuller another good
option for men with thin hair is the
true volume thickening shampoo from Jack
Black and I also have a good nourishing
hair and scalp conditioner that you can
use women mother shampoo uses this
unique blend of ingredients that helps
your hair follicles to be healthier
which overall helps your hair to look
thicker and better I'm not gonna go into
a lot of detail here because I want this
video to stay in short and sweet but as
always I'll add it for in the video
description so you can go and check it
out now let's move on now if you're
struggling with hair loss you're not
alone this around well research says
that it's around 2 out of every 3 guy so
will start to lose their hair after the
mid-thirties right which is a lot of
people so you're not alone but there are
good products and supplements that you
can use that will really help you out as
always I'll add it for in the video
description but this video is only about
the shampoo and conditioner so first
shampoo that will help you with your
hair growth is biotin now this is
probably the best shampoo out there in
the market why well it's an
extra-strength
B complexion poo and it uses all natural
ingredients to promote hair growth and
it slows hair loss another good option
is the a recovery shampoo and
conditioner from all tracked labs now
they contain a lot of good stuff but
most importantly they contain powerful
caffeine compounds which have been shown
to reduce hair loss helps hair growth
and blocks the effects of the testerone
in the skin
if you're struggling with dandruff the
passion pool out there for you is Nezzer
oh they've been around for a very long
time they're a trusted brand and they're
very hard to beat why well the stuff
just works they deliver on their promise
one of the best tips I can give you
whenever you look at products when you
want to buy products don't focus so much
on their advertising I mean today's
advertising you can trust it look at the
customer reviews a lot of three in the
video description so you can go ahead
and check it out check out those
customer reviews of guys like you and me
that tried it out already now if you
want a good drugstore product you can
try dove two-in-one anti-dandruff yes
they are good and they will help now
let's move on
[Music]
now if you struggle with dry and damaged
hair you can try out argan oil from art
Naturals now the argan oil is very
popular most people know that I help
repair and restore damaged dry hair
another great option for dry and damaged
hair is American Crew daily moisturizing
shampoo and conditioner
so what are the best overall air shampoo
and conditioner for men we'll first up
career and soon a it's infused with
natural ingredients like tea tree oil
and peppermint which will also help you
with dry scalp and dandruff smells great
and in delivers on its promise another
good one is the every man-jack suing one
for all hair types every man-jack has
high quality but affordable grooming
products made just for guys and they're
all natural tuned one shampoo and
conditioner will leave your hair
stronger softer and the healthier not
just the last tip you guys don't wash
your hair every single day why if you do
that you're gonna strip your hair of all
the natural oils and it's gonna leave
your hair to dry so wash it only around
two to three times a week that will keep
the natural oils in there keep your hair
moisturized and looking healthy and good
if you liked the video give it a thumbs
up subscribe and I'll see you in the
next video cheers guys